[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabby HD here and
usually when you see a piece of tech
that is way cheaper than the others in
the category like wave Euler you just a
fall so thinking it's probably inferior
in every way but the Moto G 5 and the
Moto G 5 plus are the result of Motorola
and not really cutting down from high
rent flagships but more building up as
high as they can for a certain price and
they've come up with this this year for
230 bucks they're still killing it in
the budget game so I want to shine
another light on this because of the
fact that I keep coming back to you that
good phones are getting cheap and cheap
phones are getting good probably the
biggest difference between this gen Moto
G and a last one is just the outside the
design and the hardware the Moto G has
always been this shamelessly
apologetically plastic but this year it
steps up to metal so all around the back
and the side and the frame and it feels
a lot better and more durable as a
result now the looks are a little more
polarizing it definitely still looks a
little bit better because of the metal
but it also definitely still looks like
a budget phone it's the bezels that are
still big on the sides and the forehead
and the chin no doubt about that and
it's a pretty basic design from top to
bottom nothing too crazy about it button
placement is standard the headphone jack
still at the bottom of all of that is
great but one thing that makes this feel
a little more cheap is actually the
chrome rail like all the way around the
bezel you don't see that really in like
the renders but in real life it actually
does make a difference I feel like on
the more premium phones the bezels are
usually just more shrinking down or much
more dark to sort of fade out the way
but the chrome here around the rails is
much more reflective kind of reminds me
of the Galaxy Nexus just a little bit
less curvy but that's not really a bad
thing it's just something you notice
about the phone the one thing I would
say I don't really like about the design
on the outside of the new Moto G is that
the old camera lump on the back I really
think if this phone was the exact same
size but didn't have that big bump
sticking out it would look pretty clean
but this sticks out of it so much that
it's a defining feature of the way this
phone looks the Moto Z had that big old
camera bump because it was a fitting
spot for all the Moto mods that fit on
the back I don't think you had to have
this big camera bump on the
the g5 because there are no motor mods
for this one either way though overall
the build quality and film hand is a
step up from last year and when you
compare to other smartphones under 300
bucks which there aren't many of this
sits up at the top pretty clearly in my
book so the specs of the new Moto G are
also decidedly mid-range about what
you'd expect a 3000 milliamp hour
battery in this g5 Plus and there are
two versions of it one with 4 gigs of
RAM and 64 gigs of storage that's 300
bucks
and then this $230 cheaper version of
the phone has 2 gigs of ram and 32 gigs
of storage that is expandable though
since the phone does keep that rare
micro SD card slot and the software
experience of the Moto G is pretty
classic motorola mostly pure stock
Android but with some enhancements that
they feel will make it better and I
really like that about them that's
something they've kept where they really
don't they don't have a whole skin on
top of Android you don't have a whole
suite of redundant apps it's nothing too
crazy it's again near stock but when
they have certain software or hardware
features they like to integrate them to
take advantage of each other so when
they have an OLED display for example
they like to take advantage of that with
software so one main place they saw for
enhancement on this phone was the home
button and it kind of stems from a weird
place from a being budget but this phone
has a weird home button situation
there's one big physical home button
with a quality fingerprint reader down
at the bottom but then there's no back
or multitasking buttons on either side
of it it's just blank space and a wasted
chin but then on the screen you can have
fully normal software buttons your back
home and multitasking but of course they
take obscure miel estate and not
everybody wants that so their unique
solution for people who want to use all
off screen buttons is what they've
called home button gestures apparently
the home button is actually big enough
to use sort of like a big glass trackpad
it's actually sensitive enough to figure
out what you're doing if you're doing a
button press versus a gesture and these
seem to work fairly well so when you
turn these on its a tap to go home then
it's a hold for a second to turn the
screen off then you can hold a little
longer to get into Google assistant then
you can swipe right across the home
button to go back and then swipe left
across the button to go to recent apps
and you can actually interchange those
last two if you want to swipe right or
left another enhancement here in stock
Android to the Moto G is gestures to go
into multitasking you basically just
drag the window up to the
I actually think this is better and
easier to remember them before so you
kind of dragged into the multitasking
experience and dragged out of it makes
sense and then there's other little
things like the slightly transparent
theme in the app drawer and the Moto
widget so you get on your home screen
that show the battery and the time and
all that stuff the screen off gesture
that came with the original Moto X you
have the double chop to turn on the
flashlight which is familiar
you have the double twist which launches
the camera really quickly that's still
there
so all those gestures and all those
enhancements come down to the Moto G
again and they're awesome
so I've said a lot of good things about
this phone but it's not your perfect
flawless fantasy phone it's definitely
not quite perfect in order to get a
phone down into the price that you get
this one in two you got to make some
trade-offs obviously to cut costs for
one thing it's still using microUSB down
at the bottom which isn't a huge deal
you could say that it's really just fine
if most people don't use USB type-c yet
but I would have liked to have seen USB
C and then this is also missing NFC
which was a bit of a bigger deal on a
certain other phone but that phone was
claiming to be a flagship killer this
one's not claiming to be any of that
it's just a lower priced phone so it
doesn't have the NFC chip that may or
may not be a big deal to you based on
how often you use mobile payments and
then the speaker up at the front it's
it's decent it's definitely not the
loudest and not the clearest out there
but the thing is it's better than most
of the high-end flagship smartphone
speakers nowadays strictly because it's
front-facing so it doesn't have to be as
loud because it's pointed right at you I
just wish it was a stereo pair since its
kind of weird holding the phone sideways
and then having the audio come from one
side of the phone and I think the camera
is the area will you'll see the biggest
drop-off the quickest drop-off from when
you had a high-end flagship phone to
this lower price on paper it's still a
12 megapixel smartphone with an F 1.7
aperture but it doesn't have optical
image stabilization so you can get
pretty good shots out of this camera
when you're really well lit and when
you're outdoors only have a lot of light
but as soon as you start to lose light
you're gonna see a lot more things like
noise in the frame because it's raising
the ISO to shorten the shutter speed to
keep that motion blur down you're gonna
see chromatic aberration you're gonna
see a lot less dynamic range a lot more
contrast and overall just a lot less
natural colors it's not quite as good of
an image processing and Motorola's
struggled with high-end cameras and
their best phones so this is definitely
not gonna be the phone you buy for the
camera quality but at the end of the day
when you start comparing this moto G to
a lot of the other phones you can get
for this
price for $250 or less it becomes really
obvious that this still falls as a
complete package at the top of the heap
so can we give the budget crown back to
the Moto G I think so yeah I think it's
gonna deserve that this moto G 5 plus
takes a lot of the cues from the bigger
more expensive brothers but it's also
coming from the low price that the Moto
G has always been in sort of elevating
it into a phone that kind of feels a lot
more like a premium flagship or at least
tries to I'd even say that the budget
flagship has previously gone for me two
phones like the one plus three and the
one plus three T but now those are sort
of creeping up into like 400 $450 price
ranges they're kind of edging up there
and starting to compete with flagships
now so for the best phone that you can
get under 300 bucks it's kind of a
no-brainer moto G is holding that crown
so if you're ballin on a budget this is
the phone to check out this is the one
so that's been pretty much it thanks for
watching I'll leave a link to this phone
below I'll leave a link to all my other
phone reviews and other stuff below as
well talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]